there's a lot of features that came in
in C++ 11 there's a lot of features at
the birth of C++ they were amazing and
ideas with concepts in 2020 what to you
is the most justjust to you personally
beautiful or just you sit back and think
wow that's just nice and clean feature
of C++ I have written two papers for the
history of programming languages
conference which basically asked me such
questions and I'm writing a third one
which I will deliver at the history of
programming languages conference in
London next year so I've been thinking
about that and there is one play answer
constructors and destructors the way a
constructor can establish the
environment for the use of the Java type
for an object and the destructor that
cleans up any messes at the end of it
that is the key to C++ that's why we
don't have to use garbage collection
that's how we can get predictable
performance that's how you can get the
minimal overhead in many many cases and
have really clean types it's the idea of
constructor destructor pairs sometimes
it comes out under the name our high a
III resource acquisition is
initialization which is the idea that
you grab resources and the constructor
and release them and destructor it's
also the best example of why I shouldn't
be in advertising I get the best idea
and I call it resource acquisition is
initialization not the greatest naming
I've ever heard
so it's types abstraction of types you
said I want to create my own types so
types is an essential part of C++ in
making them
is the if it is the key part and GU the
this is almost getting philosophical but
the construction and the destruction the
creation of an instance of a type and
the freeing of resources from that
instance of a type is what defines the
object is uh that's a little is like
birth and death is what defines human
life yeah that's right by the way
philosophy is important you can't do
good language design without philosophy
because what you are determining is what
people can express and how this is very
important
by the way constructors destructors came
into C++ in 79 in about the second week
of my work with what was then Corsi the
classes it is a fundamental idea
next comes the fact that you need to
control copying because once you control
as you says birth and death you have to
control taking coffees which is another
way of creating an object and finally
you have to be able to move things
around so you get the move operations
and that's the set of key operations you
can define on a C++ type inserts you
those things are just a beautiful part
of C++ that is at the core of it all yes
you